today we're going to be speaking with Dr
John Crystal who's a psychiatrist and
Yale University Professor may be best
known for the discovery of the rapid
antidepressant effect of ketamine in
depressed patients uh Dr Crystal really
great having you on I appreciate it
really a pleasure to be here today so
maybe to start with before we talk about
ketamine specifically it'd be great to
hear from you a little bit about
depression more generally you know you
talk to five different psychiatrists
you'll often get five at least slightly
different answers about to what degree
is depression situational or caused by a
chemical or hormonal imbalance or some
combination or it depends on the
particular case what's your sense of our
best understanding about depression at
this point
sure so I I think there are some things
that we can all agree on one that it's
far more common than we ever thought
two that it has far more detrimental
effects on people's lives than we
probably had previously appreciated
and and three that a lot of people who
try to get treatment for depression find
that the treatment that they start out
with isn't giving them the kind of full
response that that they're looking for
and and as a result even for many people
who are in treatment depression
continues to take a toll on them and I
think another thing that we would agree
about depression is that um it's really
fundamentally different than having a
bad day now we've all had a bad day
we've all probably had moments of of
Despair even but to sit in that state
all day every day or most of every day
um is a totally different experience
that is hard to appreciate if you
haven't been through it yourself
and so
um when we get to questions of causes we
have to appreciate that there are an
enormous depression is a very broad term
and there are probably many different
kinds of depressions and unfortunately
this is one area where Psychiatry has
not really
um
led us to a satisfactory place in other
words we appreciate that there are
different types of depression that
people might have some that are purely a
reaction to
um bereavement or getting fired or
having your marriage break up and where
where you have an issue or a problem
that you just can't kind of work through
in it and it and it takes you down into
this really negative place
but there clearly are other people who
have depression that comes on as you
point out because of a hormonal
imbalance because of a medical problem
uh because of other other kinds of
things going on in the body and and
we're we know a lot more about the
interplay between the body and the Brain
in relation to depression that we than
we ever did before and one of the things
that we've learned is that medical
problems in the in the body heart
disease asthma
arthritis all of these things even
obesity
um can contribute to a process in the
body called inflammation which when we
think of inflammation in our joint we
think of a sore joint when we think of
inflammation in the brain it affects the
way that the circuits are regulated and
can contribute we think to depression
but but there is also probably a genetic
contribution about 30 or so of the risk
for depression is is genetic and one of
the things that you can see in some
people who don't have a major life
stress and don't have a medical problem
contributing is that some people out of
the blue just part of their own makeup
will will experience into depression and
that's that's really important in all of
these cases
uh you know whether it's a primarily
stress primarily hormonal primarily
um uh genetic vulnerability they're
still we're talking about this very kind
of complex interplay of a person in
their surroundings and and so it's not
surprising that we treat depression
sometimes with Psychotherapy sometimes
with medications sometimes with both and
and other things like getting a lot of
social support getting good exercise
having a healthy diet can all help
people uh be uh make get their best
chance of of recovering from their
depression so before we talk about
ketamine just briefly
um treating depression with ssris from
the research I did before our interview
it seems like it's pretty clear that the
ssris work better than Placebo they
don't necessarily work
at numbers that are incredibly
overwhelming it's not 90 but it does
seem better than Placebo is that still
your understanding and what exactly are
ssris doing in the brain yeah so
um so first absolutely ssris are
extremely helpful for many people and
and so I'd say if if people were just
starting their
um having their first experience of
depression and they get treated with
with an SSRI that they could expect
about a 50 50 chance of of getting
better from that that SSRI but the
reality is that that
um that one of the things that we've
learned about depression for many people
perhaps because of the complex interplay
that we were talking about is that it
can be a chronic or recurring disorder
and so what sometimes happens uh is that
people who maybe in their first episode
responded to the SSRI find that lay
later on the medication isn't working so
well
so how ssris work is to raise the level
of Serotonin bathing the brain by
preventing its reuptake after release so
it does increase the brain's exposure to
to
um to uh depression and then it's the
brain's reaction to having so much
serotonin around that evokes adaptive
changes in the brain that that help the
regulation of mood and other aspects to
function better and
um and this process is dependent on the
ongoing availability of serotonin in the
brain so if you stop the SSRI abruptly
many people will find that their
depression symptoms will come back or if
you just deplete the body of Serotonin
to deplete the brain of Serotonin even
though people are staying on the on the
SSRI medications they may have a
transient relapse and that was done for
research purposes to help to understand
how these medications work so that's a
general introduction to the ssris so
let's now talk a little bit about
ketamine
um maybe what what is ketamine what were
some of the early medical uses that at
least it was tested for and then how how
did this start to become something that
was thought of as maybe effective for
depression
yeah well to me it's a remarkable story
so ketamine
is a drug that was identified as an
anesthetic medication in the in the
1960s
and a a a a good friend and and
colleague
um uh Dr Ed Domino
first gave this drug to people and
helped to describe its peculiar effects
which he and others call dissociative
anesthesia which is its capacity to
produce a kind of Twilight State
um that those people sometimes call
dissociation
and
um the uh they didn't know how it worked
when they discovered it in fact the
field of Neuroscience really didn't
figure out how ketamine worked until the
1980s
and then what we've what was found out
then was that um ketamine works by
blocking the action of glutamate at one
of its receptors called the nmda subtype
of glutamate receptor now you might say
wait I've heard of Serotonin before I
haven't heard of glutamate and and how
is that why would you think of glutamate
for depression so this gets back to in a
way the logic that carried us to test
ketamine first into press patients which
is that for a long time from from the
first identification of these
transmitters to I'd say certainly the
the the mid to late 1990s maybe even
later most people thought of depression
as a disorder of the norepinephrine like
noradrenaline or serotonin systems of
the brain these are chemical systems in
very primitive parts of the brain that
project to the higher centers of the
brain and tune the activity of these
higher brain Setters so they reasoned if
serotonin was a ride not functioning
right maybe if we give we give
um a serotonin reuptake inhibiting drug
will treat the symptoms of the
depression by normalizing serotonin
well
um researched by several groups
including the work done here at Yale by
my colleague Dennis Charney and Pedro
Delgado George henniger and others they
showed that if you deplete the body of
Serotonin you don't produce depression
if you deplete the body of
norepinephrine you don't produce
depression and that the biology of
depression is is is more complicated in
some ways this was a kind of
intellectual crisis moment for the
thinking about the biology of depression
and and the way that uh Dr Charney and I
reasoned our way around this problem was
to say well maybe if depression doesn't
predominantly live in the serotonin or
norepinephrine nerve cells themselves
maybe depression lives in the targets of
of norepinephrine and serotonin the
higher brain centers and the two main
brain centers we thought of were the
cerebral cortex the highest executive
control of our thought and behavior and
emotion and the limbic system the
generators are drivers of emotional
experience in the brain
and and with that came a kind of an aha
moment which is if
if
um depression is a cortical disorder
not not a brain stem disorder then the
intrinsic signaling mechanisms of these
higher brain centers the main
information highways of the higher brain
centers
should be involved in depression in its
treatment
and those information higher uh
information highways involve the
neurotransmitter glutamate as the main
excitatory neurotransmitter of the
cortex like 90 percent of the synapses
so we thought Let's test a drug that
blocks one of these glutamate receptors
the drug we chose to do that was
ketamine and what we found was this
rapid Improvement in mood Within
24 hours say of of a single dose Academy
in a large number of the people we
tested what is the dosage idea when it
comes to ketamine is it the type of
thing that is a is taken daily like an
SSRI do the effects fall off similarly
or differently like is it how how would
it be administered right so so
um Time magazine called ketamine the
anti-antidepressant and and that is
because it doesn't work like anything
else we know first unlike a medication
that you give a little bit of the drug
you don't have much effect of the drug
and you take it every day as part of
your daily life that's not at all what
ketamine is like what ketamine is is you
give a dose that that is high enough to
be to trigger the antidepressant
response
and
um and those antidepressant effects last
a week or two uh for in people and so
people generally start getting two doses
a week then after a month or so one dose
a week then every other week and so when
people are maintained on it if they need
to be maintained on it they they may
only get a dose once every three weeks
or once a month and by spreading it out
people don't become tolerant to it they
tend to if anything to become uh more
sensitive to the antidepressant effects
and it turns out in the long-term data
with s ketamine the S the the version of
ketamine developed by Jansen
that it's very helpful in preventing
relapse of depression and so that it's a
good long-term treatment as well as a
strategy for producing a rapid
antidepressant response and to help
people who haven't previously responded
to antidepressant medications are the
doses large enough when they are given
that they have a sort of psychoactive or
maybe dissociative type effect
when given in the way that we end both
we and our laboratory with ketamine and
later Jansen with s ketamine
give ketamine yes they tend to produce
psychoactive effects they can make
people feel Spacey they can have altered
sensory perception they might experience
for example that their arm or their
fingers feel longer or they may have a
feeling that the room is breathing in or
out and what we find is that if we
prepare people for those kinds of
effects if we're with them when they are
having those experiences and then if we
can have the chance to talk about them
afterwards that that people can both
understand what's going on not find it
very frightening and and have overall a
good experience last thing I wanted to
ask about what's the the sort of
regulatory and legal status right now of
using ketamine in this way per the FDA
yes so s ketamine the S isomer of the
ketamine molecule ketamine comes in two
mirror images and so one of the mirror
images uh the S isomer of ketamine is
developed and uh by Jansen and approved
by the FDA for the treatment of
treatment resistant depression and
depression in the context of suicide
risk
the standard ketamine that's used in
anesthesia is approved by the FDA for
anesthesia right and what that means is
that doctors can prescribe the Racine
ketamine for the whatever they want but
it is not approved by the FDA for the
treatment of depression and that means
that doctors who are prescribing this
form of ketamine have some additional
liability because it's not endorsed by
the FDA also the consequence of it not
being approved by the FDA is that some
insurance companies only cover the
ascadamine version that the s-ketamine
version is given as a nasal spray
and people take a certain number of
puffs of the nasal spray that's
appropriate for them and worked out with
their doctor
and uh and uh that version of of us
Academy that that version of ketamine
the S Academy is FDA improved and and
increasingly covered by insurance and
Medicare and Medicaid we have been
speaking with Dr John Crystal who is a
psychiatrist and Yale University
Professor really interesting and we look
forward to reading more about the these
uses I really appreciate your time today
it's wonderful wonderful to be here and
to talk about this uh area so thanks for
having me on